hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play I'm scared
okay this is a game that has been
suggested for a while but I couldn't get
it to work when it was first suggested
like way way back when um but now that I
finally start to get my computer back in
order I decided to redownload and give
it a try I don't think fraps works with
it because I don't know it just didn't
seem to work right either way I'm gonna
try it with xsplit see here we go ha
Bisky oh yeah it worked huh I'm actually
surprised you guys don't know how many
times I've tried to get this to work
okay
I mean a very pixelated 3d room but that
is what it was supposed to be um the
idea is it's called I'm scared a
pixelated horror Ezz I collected a
little key little key goes to the closet
you go to the hello was it covered in
blood how suspicious how very oh hello
that always been there wait a minute hey
I need a heart in order to open it that
sounds familiar
okay I don't remember seeing this before
hello ha I'm just going down the ladder
hello this looks diabolical the door's
locked good thing I have this key it's
awfully dark yeah this feels good oh
okay that was the unlockable door okay
whoo look it's a book kill a chair and
another little keys
a rusty key that it what's this why is
this blacker oh it's a black eye oh
hello - something supposed to happen
there or is that the new Sh
okay all right then why did it stop why
it'll be a dick stop boy oh my balls oh
darn it
gosh darn it I'm trapped in a bloody
wall drum oh hello little key was
something pop out
why
I don't know what that was I don't know
what that was about to me holy crap
alright let's try to get back in it
okay hello do you know my name
Alfred where do they come from I need
something for you
hi chief aide you made a desktop for me
damn you damn you hello do you know my
name
mark gotta stop running the game on me
what what was I supposed to do I don't
know your name oh wow holy crap Sonny
Lee files started appearing in the
folder whoa there is a way to turn an
entity into data they have a life of
their own it is difficult to distinguish
them from normal computer files in our
actions of every day while we sit at the
computer this bite entity observes us
and studies our every move and fear the
game is simple follow the arrows is the
key if you get caught you lose a sound
will predict its arrival it is white
face no kidding and there's a picture
here it is a picture it's just blackness
it's just blackness that's that's real
good there okay so um okay it's weird
I've never had a computer interact are
you white face how let's play tag let's
not let's not
oh god I'm glad I'm recording this an
expert okay follow the arrows is cutie
what that what does that say I'm crying
you're crying
ha I hear you boys listen gray huh help
help you help me sure you what cut the
arrows
what am I supposed to listen to here I
don't know I don't know little blue tree
I'm in a parking garage
ha ha ha oh god oh god oh god I'm Bona
Bona moon help help you screw you I'm
crying blah blah blah gone in circles
now what's over here hello big iron gate
where did the guy go I'm into the guy
hot rod argh
screw you shut up shut up already gone
that way shut up shut up okay I think
I've hit most of the arrows I hear him
mr. Whiteface are you how are you I
heard get good lucky do i guy are you re
re you shut up now
you shut up you okay I don't know what
the darn intern
don't know what to do Turner what to do
I ought dammit oh he's back he's back
okay
and I should read more of these I'm
trying oh oh here you're locked up off
gosh darn it oh where is he where is it
he's gonna come back hey goddamn I got
me we got another file here that's just
something out slowly
so I'm supposed to walk slow okay
back in it let's play tag I walk it too
slowly I walk
oh so slowly looking good I walk a
oh so softly flick look look I walk like
a like a tiger walking on Aleppo dry air
flow go your FLOTUS I say after your
slowness I'm going away
here's I hear like a key jingling I
don't know what the deal is I then
there's this door that pops up
ah wah wah dah
where are you where are you boy do you
screw you and everything you ever cared
about if you cared about anything ha
Remi God darn it that guy's persistent I
thought I saw something like what was
with the giggling was with like the
giggling voice oh hey back Hey
well good I was wondering when who's
gonna be back I don't know I don't know
so good you could be Kazee balls what do
i do what do i do what do we do
what about going going
one more was that the last arrow maybe I
don't know I don't know I'm going by
clap cooing and outside so I can leave
ha ha ha ha ha
the door is locked I'm crying
let me read these things let's see
so don't sit down no I don't know what
that says it might be backwards after
you oh it is backwards okay after you
help burly right like he's come around
me ah I see you [ __ ] oh yeah what Oh
what up got Merc hot now are you hey
what are you going on
oh wait what's going on top down a
pillar oh yeah right get away
alright so oh that was the last one oh
come on
don't screw with me like that okay
dingdong doors open I'm out here yeah ah
and the elevator oh that's not look good
where am I now where am I now where am I
now
cannot see oh okay bye Siwon I love
watching one of them is logging one of
them is lying what do i fire ah I hey
hey get back in the game here okay oh
hello gate key okay so if I go back and
I do the gate key and then I'll be good
right I'll be able to go home I don't
get the feeling that my desktop is not
gonna be safe after I play this game
what the hell
yeah okay I can't go that back that way
oh hello pit of doom
let's see am I almost back to where
hello lady are you doing you look so
fine
hey that doors locked but isn't this the
hallway where I got the pulsating heart
did I already have the pulsating heart I
swear isn't this the hallway where I
think I think so it is isn't it yeah cuz
then I go back maybe I already have it
maybe I still have the pulsating heart
give me honor
the end I win all right
holy hell I get maybe it's not the end
game didn't close so maybe it's not the
end and I got to try some okay oh hello
ha ha oh it opened by Webb
haha well done haleh crap
well done there's another one says it's
not going to let you go I shouldn't have
told you to go on follow my instructions
don't let the game's appearance deceive
you from now on things changes it
arrives take some time and try to escape
the game is not over
I don't think the game is over now and
I'm gonna go back in to check this haha
things have changed
oh the game is not over oh man this is
messed up alright one the door's locked
okay wow it is right in here is open
this ah
first thanks selected key number one
you're number one I'm going door number
one
Oh locker room number one window number
one premiere huh no that was anything oh
yeah the key is too far away not for
these arms uh I'm in the table okay so
what is the dealio my design never gonna
be able together get it ever ever ever
ever ever ever ever ever ever need to
get you far away okay I need to find
like a back scratcher something
something really long just get to whoa
hello what the hell it's like a wall of
blood that's always good son this joy /
gorlock good luck
so what do I do what do I do about that
maybe I can like snap off a leg of this
table with my brute strength ah all you
can upgrade his strength how is this an
RPG anyway okay that's like a balcony
out there I am back in the game and I
have no idea what to do I'm trying to
interact with everything but everything
is not cooperating ever thing is not
going along with
what I needed to do hum bug shall help
me helm a bookshelf hmm maybe this is
one of the situations where I just gotta
like get out of the game
Oh kid you far away whoops okay so nope
no nothing nothing nothing nothing
nothing going back in nothing there was
nothing there is nothing I don't think I
was supposed to quit there gotta be
something else some some mom missing
keep getting stuck to walls duh Wow
it does not remember that I got that
okay there's a key key number one you're
number one you're number one markiplier
you're number one
keys to far away and then I sorrow I
wallow in sorrow and despair as I
contemplate my predicament and there go
I do nothing I do nothing I do the door
is locked the door is locked
the door's locked the door is locked the
door to door to door is locked doors
locked the door is locked
two hours later ah some pincers
how's even supposed to be able to see
that was there ah I don't uh I don't
even um okay I got key eight oh it did
not like that
what key where's Dori I forget another
kiss on the other side
okay barely did not like that I didn't
mean to do that
screw you screw you and uh wardrobe
o'clock oh ho oh ho I suddenly got that
feeling of dread again ah hi hello hi
hey
hey hey I can make that way too I design
hockey dick okay so this wardrobe is
locked
it's a bunch of drawers here nothing in
this room
oh don't tell me it's gonna take me ten
hours to find the exit from here again
oh that's bad that's lovely
this is still blood filled mess and I
see nothing that could possibly help me
the Wardrobe is locked mr. smiley is out
there movie you sure ugly and uglier and
extremely ugly okay so I think I think
like whoa hello oh hi someone is
apparently sorry for making me go
through all this I know
oh hi hi hi there
whoa what's up okay Oh g7o it uh it went
nice again how uh how lovely
ah okay yeah I do see your ugly ass face
yeah don't do that
no no screw screw I'm not looking at you
I'm not scared screw you I'm not scared
desktop licky and y'all shut up I do huh
stop like am i oh okay I am scared
do you bloody whoa
haha what is that what is that what is
that you're close to one key - key - oh
my Hut uh-huh like this this is Oh God
ski six oh boy
haha oh my bollocks oh good golly oh
good golly oh I can go down there or go
in here uh-huh
I can't leave can't I you're not gonna
let me leave are you
balls ah what the hell is that
ah hi hi friend
congratulations for what come to your
birthday party that no one else maybe
you made it to the end I don't think I
did I can't escape from here now no no
Oh looking at you looking at me looking
at you watch ha ha all right what do I
got get a news
oh there we go ha ha ha I killed myself
oh oh is that how it ends oh is that how
it ends that's how it ends isn't it oh
that's how it ends it's alive it's real
sorry I'm really sorry I didn't have any
other choice I'm scared I don't want to
die from now on remember this the sound
predicts its arrival wait a min node s
that's a different attention no wait
yeah something something there's a
goodbye image which is just a noose haha
I'm going back in the game just to see
what is there
oh it's just the noose hahaha that's it
that's that's the end that that's it
that's why the picture in the oh my god
that was an incredible game holy crap
you all have to play that you all have
to you have to play that that was
awesome if there was any way for me to
go back in time and tell you to play
this game for you watch this holy balls
that was amazing
that was incredible that was that was
awesome
was actually interacting with my
computer
with my computer how cool that and if I
hadn't been recording in X but none of
that would have worked like not even a
little bit of that would have worked ha
ha ha ha oh man
I'm taken aback that was amazing I was
amazing thank you guys for making that
video that was that was an absolutely
incredible game so thank you and thank
you all so much for watching go try it
linked in the description below so thank
you for watching and click the imitates
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
laughs go
target's trucks like me